diese Produkte hier drüben dürftet ihr
alle samt kennen es sind Klassiker aus
dem Supermarkt seines Pringles nicknacks
Chipsfrisch und auf meiner linken Seite
befinden sich die neuen Amazon
Eigenmarken die teils drastisch billiger
sind deshalb werden wir heute
vergleichen ob sie nur billiger oder
vielleicht sogar besser sind denn die
werden zu dir nach Hause geliefert als
ich das zum ersten Mal gesehen habe dass
Amazon eigene Produkte hat konnte ich
mein Augen real Talk gar nicht trauen
weil es sieht einfach absurd aus wenn du
so diese klassischen Produkte die Du
kennst mit einem Amazon Logo drauf
siehst dann sind sie auch noch verdammt
günstig du kannst dir teilweise Produkte
für unter 1 € nach Hause liefern lassen
also es ergibt eigentlich gar keinen
Sinn deshalb ist die Frage ob die gut
sind wirklich spannend und hier haben
wir auch schon unsere ersten Produkte
drin das erste Problem mit den Produkten
lässt sich schon am Klang erahnen aber
sieht das nicht komplett crazy aus
Amazon basic nee our Essentials
stapelchip Salz bei Amazon ich finde das
ist wirklich es hat auch so ein bisschen
was dystopisches dass es so jetzt Chips
von Amazon gibt finde ich weil sollten
die nicht eigentlich Bücher verkaufen
schauen wir mal rein und probieren wir
das erste Produkt hier haben wir unsere
Amazon stapelchips für 1,86 € und hier
drüben unsere Pringles für 2,49 € ich
finde wenn man sich die beiden
Verpackung anschaut es ist wirklich zum
Verwechseln ähnlich ja mittlerweile
gibt's auch andere stapelchips als
Pringles aber ich finde wirklich alles
der Plastikdeckel diese Lasche die hier
rausschaut die Unterseite ist ist
wirklich eigentlich fast identisch
deshalb bin ich gespannt wie groß der
Unterschied ist zumal der preisliche
Unterschied hier noch relativ moderat
ist hier sind 10 g mehr drin also 185
hier 175 und sogar bei den Nährwerten
eine Portion von 30 g hat hier 160
Kalorien und hier drüben 163 Kalorien
also es ist quasi das gleiche Produkt
öffnen wir zunächst einmal unsere
pringets Deckel ab habe ich auch lange
nicht gegessen Pringles es ist sehr
erfreulich wenn wir reinschauen die
Chips sind alle intakt das ist glaube
ich hier drüben nicht gegeben wenn ich
mich auf den Klang verlasse es ist ein
ikonisches Produkt was mich auch sehr an
meine Kindheit erinnert weil wir hatten
immer Pringles und nicht irgendwie
andere Chips am Ende hat man irendwie
probiert da noch seine Hand
reinzubekommen und so es ist schon
Klassiker muss man einfach sagen und
hier die Amazon Chips absolut identische
Funktionsweise verdammt es sind schon
leichte Unterschiede zu erkennen also
wenn man reinschaut sieht man auf jeden
Fall da ist na ja nicht allzu viel noch
intakt aber wenn man auch die beiden
farblich mal vergleicht muss man sagen
die Pringles sind so ein bisschen
dunkler geraten davon werde ich mich
nicht beeindrucken lassen denn ich werde
es gleich auch nicht mehr sehen ihr habt
es euch häuflich gewünscht wenn wir
irgendwelche Produktvergleiche machen
ich habe mir eine kleine Augenbinde
gebunden und ich werde jetzt beide Chips
blind verkosten und euch einfach sagen
geschmacklich was mir besser gefällt
also Augenbinde an die Jungs tauschen
jetzt hinter der Kamera die Chips und
ich werde gleich nicht wissen welcher
welcher ist okay das ist Nummer eins
also ich muss sagen wenn ich das so in
der Hand halte es ist vollkommen
identisch direkt probieren ich probiere
zunächst einmal diesen Chip hier also
ist auf jeden Fall dieser typische
Geschmack wobei ich fast jetzt auf den
ersten anlib sagen wür der war ein
bisschen knuspriger also bisschen nicht
knuspriger aber so ein bisschen härter
im Biss als ich Pringles in Erinnerung
habe ich glaube dass das der Amazon Chip
war kleiner Schluck Wasser zwischendurch
um den Geschmack zu neutralisieren und
jetzt probiere ich Chip Nummer zwei ich
denke das relativ eindeutig ist der
erste bei Amazon der zweite war Pringles
schauen wir mal ob es stimmt ja recht
gehabt okay krass der hier ist überhaupt
nicht schlecht ne aber okay wenn man die
noch mal se be Seite anschaut dann merkt
man auf jeden Fall den Unterschied der
Chip zerbröselt so schöner beim Beißen
hat nicht so diesen harten knack von dem
Amazon Chip also Pringles gewinnt in dem
Fall für mich gerade bei dem geringen
Preisunterschied würde ich immer den
Klassiker wen was Amazon auch im Angebot
hat sind Sachen zu den ich jetzt gar
keinen Vergleich habe Dinge wie
pestazien oder Datteln wo ich mir
eigentlich auch nur vorstellen kann dass
es keine gigantischen Unterschiede gibt
also außer dass es halt wirklich relativ
preiswert ist und was man einfach nicht
vergessen darf wenn man Amazon Prime
Kunde ist was glaube ich sehr viele
Menschen in Deutschland sind dann
kriegst du auch eine einzige Packung
davon nach Hause geliefert kostenfrei am
nächsten Tag also es ist schon echt ein
harter Angriff finde ich auf auf
Supermärkte und auf die bestehenden
Brands ich bin gespannt wie weit das
kommt also oder wie weit das führt es
gibt außerdem noch Konfitüren es gibt
Kaffee es gibt Katzen und Hundefutter es
ist wirklich sehr crazy was S jetzt da
geschaffen haben aber ich kann mir
eigentlich nicht vorstellen Amazon wird
nicht die Farm haben das ist
wahrscheinlich ein Produkt schmeißen in
den Beutel und sie die kann eigentlich
nicht schlecht sein ganz normale
geröstete pistae 4,17 € ja pistaen sind
nicht ganz günstig auch die von Amazon
nicht aber ich fand es ganz interessant
euch zu zeigen dass es auch so etwas
hier gibt ich bin echt gespannt wo das
hinführt weil es gibt ja in manchen
Städten gibt's ja schon diese Amazon
Supermärkte wo man einfach reingehen
kann ohne zu bezahlen rausmarschiert
weil es vom Amazon Konto abgebucht wird
aber das gibt's jetzt wirklich überall
in Deutschland als nächstes haben wir
hier ein Getränk von dem ich direkt eine
Palette bestellt habe den diese ganze
Palette hier kostet knapp 12 € das heißt
eine Dose die sich hier drin Bef findet
kostet 50 Cent was wirklich verdammt
billig ist für so ein Cola Mix Getränk
auch hier wieder bei Amazon darauf zu
sehen und zum Vergleich ziehen wir ein
anderes Cola miix Getränk mezo miix ganz
ehrlich so so Cola miix getränke sind
nicht mein absolutes favorite aber ich
glaube hier sollten eigentlich
Unterschiede erkennbar sein weil wir
haben wieder den gleichen Punkt das hier
gibt's seit Ewigkeiten am Markt das hier
nicht gucken wir mal ob mein Gaumen mich
täuschen wird oder ob es vielleicht
wirklich genau das gleiche Produkt ist
natürlich ebenfalls wieder mit
verbundenen Augen grundsätzlich kann ich
sagen dass solche zuckerhaltigen
Getränke wahrscheinlich eiglich nicht
das allerbeste sind was man trinken kann
gerade wenn man noch die guten
Neujahrsvorsätze hat da ist erup schon
um einiges
besser ich bin ja seit mittlerweile über
einem Jahr mit er verpartnern und
deshalb wisst ihr wahrscheinlich genauso
wie ich bestens wie das ganze System
hier funktioniert aber ihr wisst
vielleicht noch nicht dass ich
tatsächlich durch airup viel weniger
zuckerhaltige Getränke trinke wenn ihr
immer genug Wasser trinkt dann hilft es
eurem Körper gesund und fit zu bleiben
aber es gibt sogar einige Studien die
darauf hinweisen dass man wenn man viel
Wasser trinkt sogar besser abnimmt
bestätigt ist dass eine ausreichende
Flüssigkeit zuvor sich positiv auf eure
Nieren auswirkt und eure kognitive
Leistungsfähigkeit und Konzentration
verbessert mit Air habt ihr also die
Möglichkeit eurem Körper Gutes zu tun
und nebenbei müsst ihr nicht mal auf
Geschmack verzichten denn es gibt
wirklich Unmengen von leckeren Potts so
gibt's z.B psig Ananas blaubeär oder
sogar Cola für mehr Infos Check den Link
in der Videobeschreibung oder Scann den
QR-Code dann schauen wir mal welches
colam miixgränk mir besser schmeckt wenn
wir auf Kalorien und Zutaten schauen
dann geht das schon wieder sehr in die
gleiche Richtung hier haben wir 32
Kalorien auf 100 ml hier 37 so und dann
lege ich mal wieder meine altbekannte
Augenbinde an 50 und95 Cent ist fast
doppelt so teuer wenn es jetzt ähnlich
gut schmeckt dann haben wir einen
eindeutigen Sieger Jungs macht eure
Magie vertauscht was das Zeug hält und
ich werde probieren okay probieren wir
zuerst Nummer eins wenn ich mir metzumix
im Restaurant bestellen wde das bekommen
wde würde ich jetzt nicht nachfragen
also es könnte auf jeden Fall metzoix
sein probieren wir Nummer zwe boah das
ist metzoix das hat diesen Nachgeschmack
ich bin mir sicher ohne den Vergleich zu
haben hätte ich gedacht okay das ist not
bad aber das schmeckt viel viel viel
eindeut nach dem Produkt was man
irgendwo schon kennt was man auch nicht
vergessen darf ist dass es natürlich
nicht das Beste ist was man tun kann
dass man sich so eine Dose für 50 Cent
nach Hause bestellt weil die muss
transportiert werden die muss gelagert
werden ich frage mich auch ganz ehrlich
wie das funktionieren kann weil die
können ja niemals zum marktstatt diese
absurden Mengen abnehmen dass das so
günstig wird wahrscheinlich machen die
daran sogar Verlust und wollen das
gerade irgendwie auf dem Markt spielen
keine Ahnung es ist irgendwie irgendwie
hasse ich es auch probieren wir das
nächste machen wir weiter mit Chips zum
einen habe ich hier einmal Funny Frisch
Chips frisch ungarisch kenntb glaube ich
jeder sind wahrscheinlich so mit die
bekanntsten Chips in Deutschland nicht
meine Lieblingschips aber ein guter
Vergleich zu den Amazon our Essentials
Kartoffelchips Paprika ich denk jetzt
vielleicht ist ungarisch Paprika das
gleiche wir haben extra auf die
Zutatenliste geschaut also hier ist
räucherpaprika drin hier auch Paprika
Zwiebelpulver relativ identisch das
ganze hier haben wir eine Packung mit
200 g und diese Packung hat 150 g hier
haben wir also 50 g mehr drin bei 1,31 €
das hier kostet 1,99 also
Preisunterschied ist auf jeden Fall da
Amazon wieder günstiger aber wir schauen
einfach mal rein okay krass also es geht
geruchlich in eine sehr ähnliche
Richtung kann ich ja vor mir sollte ich
jetzt irgendwo die zwei Packungen oder
tyten Chips haben wir reden nicht lang
rum ich probiere Nummer ein nach ersten
Probieren wür ich direkt sagen
Chipsfrisch kenne ich den Geschmack
relativ typisch aber es ist die Frage ob
die jetzt genauso schmecken oder ob die
sich irgendwie abheben ich B so gut
darin das ist Chipsfrisch das hat diese
süße hinten raus die anderen haben nicht
die süße aber e ohne Witz die schmecken
fast gleich ich bin mir aber sicher dass
das hier Chipsfrisch ist weil die haben
diese charakteristische süße nimm mal
ab ihr hab mich verarscht oder Nein echt
nicht nein ihr hab mich gerade so
abgefeiert dass ich so gut bin darin
habt ihr mich ret nicht verarscht Alter
die schmecken mehr nach Chipsfrisch als
Chipsfrisch ihr habt mich verarscht nein
okay da geht der Sieg preislich
preisleistungstechnisch ganz klar in
Amazon und anders als bei den
stapelchips sind die auch noch intakt
angekommen erster Sieg für Amazon die
hier sind echt nicht verkehrt muss ich
ganz ehrlich sagen wenn ihr aber richtig
gut Chips wollt dann gibt's natürlich
noch bessere beispielsweise die Chips
von Rob weiter geht's mit einem
absoluten ernährungstrend den natürlich
auch Amazon nicht auf der Strecke lässt
Proteinriegel oder generell
fitnessernährung gibt es auch bei Amazon
man muss direkt ein großes Paket
bestellen hier sind 12 Riegel drin
diesen Vergleich werde ich jetzt
allerdings ohne Augenbinde machen weil
wir haben nicht die identische
Geschmacksrichtung gefunden auch der
Name ist krass ne mfit mfit guck mal das
finde ich wirklich so viel besser als
diese ganze our Essentials Kacke weil
das ist die haben D die sich Mühe
gegeben und haben zumindest so eine
kleine Brand entwickelt wobei das heißt
mfit eat das ist irgendwie auch so so
nicht sagen mfit eat was soll sonst
damit machen mfit Stick in your ass oder
was zum Vergleich eine ESN designerb die
kostet im Supermarkt 2,60 € hier sind
wir bei 88 Cent 20 g Protein 19,5 g
Protein also not bad probieren wir mal
crispy chocolate ich glaube der markus
rül hat erklärt dass dieses cremige was
da drin ist irgendwie so Methylalkohol
oder so und das hat so diesen typischen
fitnessriegelgeschmack auch die süße die
so aus dem Proteinpulver kommt oder wie
auch immer ist auch relativ typisch
Fitness schmeckt mir gar nicht mal so
gut muss ich ganz ehrlich sein probieren
wir jetzt mal mfit eat low sugar Protein
war ich habe es endlich gefunden die
Nährwerte und alles stehen auf der Box
die man bekommt und hier hat ein Riegel
mit 60 g 212 Kalorien hier 194 also bei
Amazon sind es weniger Kalorien knapp 20
Kalorien weniger aber nichtsdestotrotz
ich glaube das ist schon auch ein Faktor
auf den man achtet wenn man sehr
sportbeggeistert ist sieht irgendwie
ganz lecker aus mit so crunchy Stückchen
oben drauf auf und so einem sieht fast
aus wie so eine Fett kakaoglasur
probieren wir das gute Stück einmal der
schmeckt wahrscheinlich wie so ein
richtiger oldschool Riegel so wie so
einer der allerersten Proteinriegel die
manessen vor 5 Jahren von DM dieser
Protein Big Block was so ein
riesenriegel ist der so richtig den Mund
verklebt wo du ewig kauen musst aber du
hast oben drauf auch so ein bisschen
dieses creamy Zeugs aber die eigentliche
Masse schmeckt nicht gut man merkt den
Preisunterschied und Amazon verliert
klar klarer Sieger ist für mich auf
jeden Fall er auch wenn es fast dreimal
so teuer ist bin gespannt wir haben noch
einige Produkte die wir testen wollen
wir haben noch nicknack wir haben Wein
denn Amazon hat tatsächlich auch eigenen
Wein und Cola du darfst was aussuchen er
machen wir Wein mit ein Gläschen Wein
arbeitet sich doch am besten wir hab mit
einem ähnlichen Preispunkt einem
Supermarkt gekauft und hier drin
befinden sich unsere Amazon weine ich
habe drei Stück bestellt ich wusss noch
nicht genau welchen wir testen werden
jetzt haben wir uns für shardon
entschieden und das sieht schon wieder
einfach falsch aus chadon Victoria
Australia ein australisch Chardon
exclusively by Amazon ich find es
wirklich auch wieder absolut eigenartig
dass man ein Wein hat auf dem Amazon
steht bei dem Wein werde ich euch ganz
einfach stumpf sagen was mir besser
schmeckt weil ich kenne mich nicht gut
genug mit Weinen aus um zu sagen wie
lieblich oder trocken dieser Wein hier
ist einmal Amazon ich meine alleine dass
der aus Australien kommt für 4,49 € s
aber vielleicht schmeckt ja und hier
drüben dieute biorebe aus dem Supermarkt
kommt aus Italien zwei Weine es gibt
bestimmt Leute die wesentlich meh
darüber sagen können als ich eine
leichte Perlage bei beiden einige
Schwebstoffe riechen erstmal Amazon
riecht fruchtig ich krieg ein bisschen
weiße Frucht und hier drüben R ein
bisschen trockener probieren wir mal
Amazon Weißwein okay auch ziemlich
trocken auch neutralisieren
erstmal und jetzt der
supermarktwein schmecken mir beide nicht
so gut um 12:30 Uhr beide haben
verloren ich mag beides nicht sorry
beide Weine schmecken mir nicht aber hey
es es gibt beide bei Amazon jetzt wisst
ihr wenigstens das und sie schmecken mir
zumindest nicht weiter mit nächsten
Produkt wir haben noch zwei Produkte die
es beide jeweils wirklich in sich haben
und ich weiß auch schon was sich hier
drin befindet es sind nämlich die Amazon
nicknex die wirklich den unschlagbaren
Preis von 1,11 € haben du kannst ja das
für 1,11 € bestellen und nach Hause
liefern lassen es ergibt abermals
überhaupt gar keinen Sinn und hier
drüben ist das Original nicknex für 2,99
€ ich finde optisch sieht das hier viel
weniger aus es ist aber genau gleich
viel drin also beide haben 170 g
leichter Unterschied im Farbton aber ich
muss sagen ansonsten es riecht einfach
nach nicknack für mich Augenbinde an und
probier grüy vertauscht den Bums wieder
bitte schiebst nur vor und zurück okay
beginnen wir mit unserem Test hier ist
Schlüssel Nummer 1 mit einer Erdnuss im
Teigmantel probieren wir Erdnuss im
Teigmantel Nummer 1 also schmeckt für
mich nach nckn okay probieren wir Nummer
zwei wir haben irgendwie mehr Arom da
ist so ein bisschen ist mehr so Kräuter
Action dabei aber vom Crunch her von der
Nuss gibt sich das nicht viel es ist
einfach nur die Würzung die sich
unterscheidet hier sind nicknacks hier
ist Amazon und ich finde die Würzung von
diesen sogar geiler schauen wir mal ob
ich recht habe erstmal ja Amazon ist
hier drüben also das Produkt ist
basically genau das gleiche es ist
einfach nur anders Gewürz hier so ein
bisschen mehr weiß nicht so Rosmarin
thman dabei und bei dem Preisunterschied
gleiches Gewicht ist Amazon für mich
definitiv der Sieger ich habe es ein
bisschen erkannt weil das diesen
typischen nicknack Geschmack hat aber
wie gesagt Amazon wollte ja nicht
kopieren die haben einfach nur eigene
Produkte gemacht in dem Fall gefällt es
mir sogar echt ein bisschen besser aber
diese erdnü im Teigmantel machen mir ein
wenig Durst Durst auf ein ikonisches
Getränk auf Cola denn auch hier hat
Amazon eine Eigenmarke wieder im
palettenformat zu kaufen und preislich
absolut identisch also hier haben wir 50
Cent pro Dose die ist auch wie beim
letzten Mal so schön eingedellt und hier
drüben sind es 95 Cent jeweils ohne fand
also mit fand 25 Cent mehr und ich bin
sehr gespannt ich werde es auf jeden
Fall auch wieder guck mal die haben sich
nicht mal die Mühe gemacht eine andere
Grafik zu erstellen die haben einfach
Orange mit rot ausgetauscht und oben was
anderes hingeschrieben aber diese Grafik
hier unten ist genau die gleiche sogar
die Farbe vom Getränk ist die gleiche
also bisschen cheap Augenbinde auf und
dann entscheidet sich ein letztes Mal ob
Amazon mit ihren Produkten trumpft also
eigentlich eigentlich muss ich Coca-Cola
erkennen Getränk Nummer 1 Bo ich mag
wirklich einfach nicht Cola oh riecht
schon ganz anders h also das hier ist
Coca-Cola das hier ist Amazon stimmt
auch wusste ich doch aber es schmeckt
auch ganz anders also das hier ist so
wie wenn so beim Cola Automaten der
Sirup ausgeht da fehlt so ein bisschen
vom Geschmack einfach das hier ist echt
süß echt pappig also ich mag es auch
nicht gerne aber das ist einfach ein
anderes Getränk das schmeckt noch mehr
nach Zuckerwasser ich muss sagen es war
verdammt interessant heute wir haben
einige Amazon Produkte getestet manche
konnten gewinnen aber durch die Bank
waren sie wirklich verdammt günstig und
es ist absurd dass man heutzutage bei
Amazon sich ein paar erdnü in Teigmantel
bestellen kann und die sind am nächsten
Tag da schreibt mal in die Kommentare
was ihr von den Amazon Produkten haltet
ob ihr sie bestellt würdet und dann
sehen wir uns beim nächsten Video wieder
bis dahin macht's gut ciao ciao